derrière le voile dans les coulisses de
la commission Stasi documentaire de
dorothéno pour Public Sénat qui dit à
quel point le sujet des signes religieux
à l'école posait question et à quel
point il avait été pris au sérieux 20
ans après de nouvelles questions se
posent lesquelles et pourquoi parlons-en
avec nos invités Jacques Grosperrin
bienvenue à vous sénateur LR du Doubs
vous êtes le rapporteur de la
proposition loi pour une école de la
liberté de l'égalité des chances et de
la laïcité proposition loi déposée en
avril dernier je précise que vous êtes
vous-même professeur agrégé Gwenaëlle
calves bienvenue à vous vous êtes
professeur de droit public à
l'université de Cergy-Pontoise vous
dirigez la formation laïcité et principe
de la République et vous avez publié ce
livre la laïcité aux éditions de La
Découverte Razika Adnani bienvenue à
vous vous êtes philosophe islamologue
vous avez écrit de nombreux ouvrages lui
en citer deux Islam quel problème les
défis de la réforme et c'est autre livre
pour ne pas céder texte et penser tous
les deux publiés aux éditions
Yanis roder bienvenue à vous vous êtes
professeur d'histoire-géographie depuis
25 ans en Seine-Saint-Denis ou diriger
l'observatoire de l'éducation à la
Fondation Jean Jaurès et vous êtes
l'auteur de ce livre la jeunesse
française l'école et la République aux
éditions de l'Observatoire merci
beaucoup à tous les quatre d'être ici et
avant tout je voudrais savoir ce que
vous retenez du film que l'on vient de
voir tous ensemble c'est une archive
historique je le disais en introduction
qui a 20 ans on a jugé nécessaire de le
rediffuser aujourd'hui dans ce contexte
de débat qu'est-ce qu'il vous a inspiré
à vous Jacques gros perron qu'est-ce que
ça vous a fait de revoir ce film et
d'entendre les réflexions les propos de
l'époque de le découvrir surtout parce
que je n'avais plus la chance de le voir
mais la prudence des politiques les
propos de Jacques Chirac lorsqu'il dit
il y aura peut-être une loi si une
initiative parlementaire il parle ce qui
montre que depuis près de 20 ans déjà
nous sommes toujours un peu dans la même
situation avec une certaine fébrilité
c'est un sujet qui est hypersensible et
il faut absolument arriver à comme on
dit sortir la poussière sous le tapis
parce qu'il faut régler un problème pas
simplement de civilisation mais un
problème de société en tout cas de la
cité en France
pensible et vous le jugez utile
nécessaire oui oui moi je découvre aussi
ce documentaire je le trouve très
intéressant et ce que j'ai remarqué
c'est que les questions posées à ce
moment-là sont les mêmes qu'on se pose
aujourd'hui aussi comme si on est encore
en 2003 les mêmes questions se posent et
c'est ça la chose qui m'a le plus frappé
il y a une histoire vous étiez déjà
enseignant à l'époque c'est pour ça que
j'ai précisé que ça faisait 25 ans que
vous étiez enseignant en
Seine-Saint-Denis cette commission a eu
lieu il y a 20 ans vous étiez jeune
enseignant qu'est-ce que vous ça vous a
fait de d'écouter ses propos est-ce que
vous étiez effectivement confrontés à ce
sujet du voilà à l'école et j'avais été
auditionné par la commission Stasi
et j'ai retrouvé en regardant ce film
que je découvrais
j'ai retrouvé des gens avec face à qui
j'avais parlé et notamment certains qui
aujourd'hui ne sont plus là et que
j'avais lu en tant que grand historien
je pense à renérémon par exemple et donc
j'ai dit voilà c'est avec une certaine
émotion aussi que j'ai regardé ce
documentaire et ce qui m'a frappé pour
répondre à votre question
c'est qu'on sent au fil du documentaire
l'évolution l'évolution au sein de la
commission où on sent qu'il y a des gens
qui voilà qui n'ont pas tellement d'avis
d'autres peut-être qu'il y en a vu plus
arrêté et on sent cette évolution
mais qui est montré par le documentaire
je pense que c'est aussi un parti pris
le documentaire vers la nécessité en
tout cas c'est comme ça que la ressort
la nécessité d'une initiative
parlementaire justement autour de la
question du voile Gwenaëlle Calvez on
sent qu'il y avait une forme d'urgence à
réfléchir au sujet qu'il manquait une
règle claire est-ce que c'est ça aussi
que vous retenez ce documentaire Le
règle clair sur le voile sur les signes
religieux à l'école alors ça c'est un
peu ce qui m'a ce qui m'a frappé dans le
dans le documentaire c'est la
polarisation sur cette affaire des
signes religieux d'accord alors que je
rappelle qu'en fait il y avait une
mission à l'Assemblée nationale la
mission de Bray qui avait pour pour
Charles de réfléchir à la question du
port de signe religieux dans les écoles
et lycée collège comme vous l'avez dit
vous-même dans votre propos de lancement
le le la mission la mission qui était
assignée par le Président de la
République à la commission Stasi était
beaucoup plus large on était à la veille
du centenaire de la loi il s'agissait si
vous lisez la lettre de mission c'est
très clair il s'agissait de réfléchir à
l'application de la laïcité de manière
beaucoup plus globale y compris dans le
monde de l'entreprise de la santé de la
santé de tous les services publics or on
voit bien dans le reportage la pression
exercée par les médias
sur la question du voile donc d'ailleurs
le président Stasi c'est un peu ému dans
le rapport final en disant qu'il y avait
trop de pression sur cette histoire de
voile et je trouve que la scène une des
scènes à la fin du reportage ou
le 5 décembre vous savez on a enfin
auditionné des jeunes filles voilées la
presse était il y avait des caméraman
partout et la jeune fille voilée
s'exprime quand elle a fini de parler
tous les cabernacles partent avec elle
et celle qui restait là sans voir la
dire bah si j'avais su j'aurais mis une
burqa si c'est ça qu'il fallait pour
être entendu parce qu'ils ont tous parti
sauf Public Sénat qui restait mais sinon
ils sont tous partis donc ça montre bien
quand même et les chefs d'établissement
le santé aussi beaucoup dans toute la
période qui a précédé dès qu'il y avait
un incident dans un établissement
l'établissement était cerné par les
journalistes mais de façon
disproportionnée c'est ce que vous
voulez
c'était quand même instrumentalisés par
les militants ça faisait la une de la
presse régionale puis le cas échéant
national et donc cette affaire du port
de signe religieux à l'école qui n'est
qu'une partie de la discussion plus
générale sur la laïcité à qui des
dimensions totalement disproportionnées
on sent bien que cette commission a
travaillé sur autre chose que le voilà à
l'école mais à l'époque le flou et mais
dans l'embarras les chefs
d'établissement c'est autour des signes
religieux à l'école enfin il me semble
radicat de Nani oui je pense qu'au début
du documentaire on a c'était dit comme
ça que le la commission Stasi avec comme
objectif de prendre position au sujet de
du voile à l'école c'est ce que j'ai
compris en tout cas mais c'est vrai que
la Commission a aussi parlé d'autres
sujets à l'hôpital à l'université et
dans d'autres domaines mais je pense que
oui la lumière est faite le plus plus
sur le voile à l'école
on dit bien à un moment donné je crois
que les problèmes sont cachés par le
voile il fait une sorte de jeu de mots
par rapport à cela et c'est moi qui
véritablement qui a c'est c'est
l'émergence c'est quelque chose c'est la
mise en lumière de quelque chose qui qui
ressurgit en tout cas on a presque
l'impression que cette commission
n'était pas nécessaire Yanis roder
est-ce qu'elle était nécessaire je veux
dire je pense à ce qu'on pourrait
appeler le péché originel de Lionel
Jospin qui laisse un flou et qui laisse
les chefs d'établissement décider on on
arrive à un moment en 2003 où on ne peut
plus laisser les chefs d'établissement
décider seul ou non oui moi je pense
qu'elle était nécessaire puisque de
toute façon le président de la
République l'avait décidé c'est la
première chose mais surtout moi je me
souviens que j'avais été auditionné je
n'ai pas du tout parlé du voile puisque
c'était pas mon sujet moi dans mon
établissement en Seine-Saint-Denis je
n'avais pas ce type de question en
revanche j'avais des questions liées au
contestation d'enseignement contestation
d'enseignement qui se basaient sur des
revendications ou des considérations
religieuses et ça c'était quel type
d'enseignement la Shoah par exemple à
l'époque la question de la naissance de
la naissance du monde etc des choses et
que les philosophes des Lumières bon des
choses qu'on connaît aujourd'hui et qui
ont été médiatisées donc aujourd'hui on
connaît oui aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
c'est quelque chose de connu à l'époque
ça n'était pas et nous étions déjà
confrontés à cela et moi j'avais j'avais
apporté un témoignage de prof de terrain
à l'époque sur ces questions là et pas
du tout sur la question sur la question
du voile donc en réalité je crois que en
tout cas moi je l'ai compris comme ça ce
qu'on m'avait demandé c'est voilà quel
était l'état de la situation en termes
de revendications religieuse radicale
puisque c'était de cela dont je
témoignait sur le terrain donc c'était
bien plus large que la question du voile
je vous voyais réagir quand j'ai parlé
de péché originel de Lionel Josselin 89
éducation je vous trouve un peu dur avec
le nage au sport au sens où
il n'a pas laissé les chefs
d'établissement livrés à eux-mêmes il a
saisi le Conseil d'État pour avis le
Conseil d'État a délivré un va des mécum
alors j'entends bien que pour appliquer
les vade-mecum délivrés par le Conseil
d'État quand on n'est pas docteur en
droit c'est peut-être pas simple en
outre il y a eu plusieurs plusieurs
circulaires la circulaire Jospin
elle-même en 89 deux circulaires Berrou
en 93 et 94 qui tirait un peu à euadia
de sorte que l'état du droit était
complexe je dirais pas flou je dirais
complexe et quand on a un établissement
à diriger on n'écrit pas une thèse sur
le droit des usagers à la liberté
d'expression on doit trouver des
solutions
donc on voit Alain Alain Touraine à un
moment donné dans l'émission alors il
est dans son rôle comme sociologue de
dire mais finalement de quoi
parlons-nous quel chiffre est-ce qu'on a
est-ce qu'on a des chiffres est-ce qu'on
connaît la réalité du monde intéressant
ce passage et ben on connaît c'est pas
les estimations disent peut-être 15
établissements ou le voile le port du
voile était autorisé c'est quand même
pas beaucoup à l'échelle de la France
alors le voilà à l'école était le sujet
qui est occupé les esprits à l'époque
ancêtre entrée 2023 ça ne vous a pas
échappé ce fut la Baya nous avons
assisté à un épisode politique et
médiatique à séoulet tout cela était-il
bien utile la commission stazine
avait-elle pas déjà tout anticiper on va
en parler ensemble juste après cette
déclaration presque visionnaire de
Ghislaine Hudson qui est membre de la
commission et qui à l'époque et
proviseur d'un lycée de Dammarie-les-Lys
en Seine-et-Marne
lorsque nous aurons interdit le voile
les foulards etc je pense qu'il y aura
un certain nombre de jeunes qui qui ont
cette allure celles qui ont cette
attitude par revendication identitaire
qui trouveront des stratégies qu'on a
même pas encore imaginé et d'autres
moyens d'expression et que sur le
terrain nous l'échelle de
l'établissement ben on restera toujours
très perplexe pour savoir ce qui relève
de l'identité et ceux qui ne le relève
pas
rasika adnanis incroyable ce qu'elle dit
là elle annonce presque ce qui est en
train de se passer aujourd'hui c'est à
dire que 20 ans plus tard les jeunes qui
ont envie potentiellement de revendiquer
une identité religieuse on trouvait
autre chose et on contournait la loi
avec la Baya oui en effet mais je pense
que ce n'est pas juste question de désir
de contourner la loi d'accord il faut
savoir que dans le monde musulman en
2003 c'était déjà il y avait déjà une
idée qu'on appelle la jurisprudence des
minorités qui a commencé à se mettre en
place après surtout le livre de karadaou
prédicateur égyptien et qui a écrit en
2001 un livre qui est l'intitulé la
jurisprudence des minorités que signifie
cette expression elle signifie que les
musulmans qui vivent en situation de
minorité en Occident doivent se
soumettre aux règles de l'islam
pratiquer la charia comme tous les
musulmans mais en cas de difficulté
comme c'est le cas de l'école en France
pour le voile il on peut on met plutôt à
leur disposition ce qu'on appelle la
jurisprudence des minorités c'est à dire
certains ajustements pour qu'ils
puissent continuer de vivre dans des
pays qui ne sont pas musulmans et le
voile faisait partie de cette
démarche légère de jeunes un peu en
rébellion que c'était beaucoup plus
profondable la politique et que la Maya
c'est aussi ça c'est beaucoup plus
profond que ça étant donné que l'idée a
été reprise par les responsables
religieux en France et aujourd'hui
beaucoup de responsables religieux
parlent aussi ils ont changé un peu
l'expression et préfèrent aujourd'hui
parler de l'adaptation du discours
religieux au contexte français donc il y
a tout un discours qui leur a dit vous
êtes toujours voilé vous enlevez votre
voile devant la porte de l'établissement
mais vous restez toujours des filles
voilées musulmane avec votre robe votre
attitude au sein de l'établissement et
vous n'êtes pas où votre foie n'est pas
altérée votre appartenance à l'islam
n'est pas du tout
gêné parce que vous êtes en situation de
nécessité donc ce n'est pas juste une
envie de contourner la loi
Calvez je pense que c'est le on a
peut-être pas forcément raison de
raisonner en termes de détournement ou
de contournement parce que la loi ne
porte pas sur des tenues le législateur
ne se préoccupe pas de question de
garde-robe la loi
porte sur la manifestation
ostensible d'une appartenance religieuse
cette manifestation
ostensible le moyen
par lequel par laquelle vous allez la
réaliser n'importe pas ce qui compte
c'est le résultat le bandana est arrivé
très tôt dans la discussion le bonnet de
laine est arrivé très tôt dans la
discussion les gants etc tout objets qui
ne sont pas en soi des objets religieux
mais qui le deviennent dans certains
contextes en raison du comportement de
l'élève parce que ce qui est visé par la
loi c'est la volonté d'afficher la
volonté de manifester ustensiblement une
appartenance religieuse après que ce
soit quelque soit la manière c'est pas
ça qui compte c'est pas ça qui est
important donc s'agit oui mais je
comprends pas une paire de gants ou un
bonnet ne ne
donne aucune manifestation religieuse je
vois pas le lien beaucoup d'élèves ont
été exclus pour port de bandana de
bandeau de gants de robe bah oui tout au
long des années 2000 parce que
manifestation de quel ordre parce
qu'elle l'utilise
dans un contexte où elle le porte elle
arbore pour manifester une soumission à
Dieu pour manifester qu'elles sont de
bonnes musulmans donc pour afficher
il y a 20 ans c'est précisément ce qui
se passe depuis des années c'est à dire
que les jeunes qui ont envie de
revendiquer quelque chose et en
l'occurrence une appartenance religieuse
le font par tous les moyens et bien sûr
d'ailleurs c'est dans la circulaire
d'application de la loi c'est dans la
circulation c'est ce que je voulais dire
que en fait ce que dit ce que dit
Ghislaine sont on le retrouve dans la
circulaire d'application du 18 mai 2014
puisque celle-ci dit que tout signe ou
vêtements qui qui amène à se faire
immédiatement reconnaître par son
appartenance religieuse et proscrit et
elle ajoute
cette cette loi est pensée pour tous les
signes qui viendraient voilà donc même
ceux qui nous échapperaient un peu parce
que
en réalité ce que l'on trouve dans la
situation puisque vous parlez de la
situation des abeilles aujourd'hui ce
que l'on voit dans la situation des
habayas c'est un peu la même chose que
ce qui se passait avant la loi de 2015
c'est-à-dire que les chefs
d'établissement
ce sont retrouvés de leur point de vue
c'est pas moi qui parle c'est
l'établissement de leur point de vue ce
sont retrouvés face à quelque chose
qu'il pensait être nouveau c'est-à-dire
la Baya faut savoir que les premières
abayas on a mention des premières zabaïa
en 2010-2011 dans un lycée dans un lycée
de Saint-Ouen à blanc qui Auguste blanc
qui exactement donc
il y a quelque chose là si vous voulez
qui rejoint ce qui se passe en 2003
c'est-à-dire cette insécurité dont a
parlé gonnael Calvez des chefs
d'établissement et il a fallu donc le le
ministre de l'éducation nationale
Gabriel Attal écrivent noir sur blanc à
Baya mais en réalité
si on suit la loi la Bayen était déjà si
vous voulez à proscrire voilà à
proscrire et proscrite et proscrite mais
il fallait rassurer la chef
d'établissement et les visionnaires
c'est vrai que moi j'ai rencontré des
chefs établissement hier en préparation
de de cette de cette soirée et qui m'ont
dit qu'ils étaient dans une situation
tellement difficile parce qu'ils en sont
assez demandés comment décrypter un
moment donné des situations de
prosélytisme qui font que qu'on connaît
qu'on connaît pas qui véritablement
montre que ces jeunes qui viennent au
sein de qui viennent défier en réalité
notre République parce que d'ici notre
République comment faire pour les être
capable de les de les déterminer alors
il me disent à un moment donné on va pas
mesurer de la jupe dans l'ensemble des
choses on s'interroge peut-être sur la
tenue scolaire ou ce qu'on appelle
l'uniforme sur l'utilité de cela
peut-être ou pas c'est un autre débat
mais les choses sont liées donc à un
moment donné je crois que les côtes
d'huile de contournement vont exister
seront de plus en plus là parce que ce
sont des coups de boutoir petit à contre
la République et les valeurs de la
République parce que les mots de
Ghislaine Nuton sont incroyables des
jeunes qui trouveront des stratégies
qu'on a même pas encore imaginé elle
sait à dire que quel que soit la loi que
l'on écrirait ça ne changerait pas grand
chose ou est-ce à dire qu'il faut
peut-être réorganiser une commission
enfin comment faire alors pour que
l'embarrasse je pense que
il suffit juste de la lire de bien la
comprendre et de l'appliquer et de
l'appliquer bien sûr mais la loi est
très bien faite circulaire
d'applications et limpide en réalité il
faut il faut que les chefs
d'établissement se sentent soutenus dans
les prises de décision qui sont les
leurs c'est je crois ce qu'a voulu faire
le ministre aujourd'hui et je crois
qu'il a bien fait parce que momentané il
y a eu un flou pendant quelques années
il y a eu un déni de la part des
politiques en tout cas d'une certaine
partie de de la classe politique la loi
est là elle existe elle est le ministre
à véritablement bien fait parce que je
crois que ça va en donner mais le poids
sous les i sur les i pardon et de la
même manière que que Jean-Michel
Blanquer l'avait fait deux référés qui
ont été déposés au Conseil d'État et le
conseil de vient de rejeter le deuxième
référé confirmant donc cette
interdiction de la du port de la baille
à l'école est-ce que pour autant
l'affaire est close selon vous je pense
que la loi de 2004 aborde la question du
voile
comme seulement un signe religieux alors
que le voile islamique n'est pas
seulement un signe religieuse c'est un
c'est une pratique de discrimination à
l'égard des femmes et si tu ne pratique
aussi qui déshumanise l'homme et qui
donne une légitimité à la violence à
l'égard de certaines femmes je pense que
sur ce point là il se pose à la laïcité
qui est qui a comme objectif de réaliser
l'égalité mais surtout les fondements de
la République française ou l'égalité est
importante mais l'aborder uniquement
comme un signe religieux et lui donner
ou le considérer ou le présenter comme
un signe qui a la même la nature que la
kippa ou le Lacroix je pense ne reflète
pas à la réalité du voile d'une part et
d'autre part donne une forme de
d'arguments à ceux qui veulent le
défendre au nom de cette même liberté
quel est votre intime conviction qu'il
faudrait réécrire un texte un texte
nouveau affiné ce texte je pense que le
problème du voile doit être abordé à
part et régler à part à part dans un
texte à part je pense comme un problème
qui est lié à je dirais à la
discrimination à l'égalité et qu'on met
pas avec la kippa le la croix ou
d'autres signes religieux il n'est pas
qu'un signe religieux d'ailleurs il a
existé
2400 ans avant notre heure et la
religion lui ont donné une légitimité
après j'entends oui ça ça me semble
totalement impossible au plan
constitutionnel et au regard de ce
qu'est la laïcité c'est-à-dire que la
laïcité ignore les distinctions entre
religion la loi de 1905 par exemple a
été rédigée pour toutes les religions de
présentes à l'époque et à venir de même
la loi de 2004 ne vise aucune religion
en particulier la laïcité on connaît le
fer religieux notamment comme sous
l'angle de la police mais ne se mêle pas
de dire de ce qui est bien ce qui est
pas bien si la si le voile est oppressif
d'ailleurs la Convention européenne
interdit totalement à l'état de se
prononcer sur le bien-fondé des
croyances des pratiques etc ça ça
regarde les religions
qu'elle fasse le ménage chez elle vous
connaissez évidemment l'islam que moi je
ne connais pas mais il me semble que au
sein de l'islam il y a des mouvements
réformateurs des mouvements féministes
de tous ordres d'ailleurs mais qui
essaie de faire bouger les choses mais
ça c'est un terme religion ça regarde
pas l'état il y a une histoire c'est
d'en parler je crois madame Anani et
fort justement c'est c'est de l'idée que
derrière le voile en réalité et derrière
la bagarre il y a un projet politique
il y a un projet politique qui est un
projet de société en réalité c'est pas
seulement comment certains le disent un
bout de un but d'un bout de tissu ou une
simple robe bien sûr que non c'est tout
ce qu'a dit Madame ananis c'est-à-dire
ce système discriminatoire à l'encontre
des femmes et qui renvoient
effectivement de l'homme une vision
extrêmement négative l'homme serait un
sauvage prêt à se jeter sur la première
femme qui passe et qui ne porterait pas
le voile ou une abeille assez ça que
cela dit donc il y a un projet politique
mais ce qui est intéressant aussi je
crois dans ce que dit Madame Nani c'est
que ce que l'on voit dans la société
française aujourd'hui et c'est pour ça
que vous avez cette poussée des abayas
depuis la rentrée pour qu'on ait un peu
une idée on est à 1200 1300 à baillas
jeune fille qui se sont présentés en
habaya devant les portes des lycées
alors j'ai pas les mêmes chiffres moi
j'ai ce annoncé par Gabriel Attal le
lundi 4 septembre le jour de la rentrée
298 élèves se sont présentés en habaya
67 ont refusé de le retirer tout à fait
depuis il se trouve qu'il s'est passé du
temps et que oui bien sûr on est autour
de 1200 depuis le début qui se présente
aujourd'hui qui se sont présentés depuis
le 4 septembre
vêtu de tenue qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
ça veut dire que finalement le fait
d'avoir interdit la Baya a provoqué
l'effet du tout pas du tout parce que
les premiers jours vous avez plusieurs
centaines et puis vous avez une décrue
très importante et aujourd'hui au jour
où au jour d'aujourd'hui on est à ça se
tient sur les doigts d'une main voilà
donc ça fonctionne voilà ce qu'a fait
Gabriel Attal ça fonctionne mais ce que
je voulais dire pour continuer sur ce
que je disais à propos de ce que dit
Madame Adnani c'est que en réalité dans
dans la jeunesse française qui se qui se
dit ou qui se pense et qui se vit
musulmane il y a un déplacement des
normes en réalité et des normes qui
étaient des qui sont des normes
défendues par une vision radicale
c'est-à-dire islamiste pour dire les
choses sont comprises aujourd'hui par
une partie de la jeunesse française
musulmane comme étant des normes
musulmanes et non plus comme des normes
islamistes c'est-à-dire que moi j'ai des
élèves qui me disent je suis musulman
donc je dois porter le voile je suis
musulmane donc je dois porter la Baya
non ce n'est pas ce n'est pas ça ce
n'est pas je crois l'islam c'est une
vision rigoriste de l'islam or c'est
intégré de plus en plus comme étant les
normes de l'islam Jacques oui oui moi je
partage complètement et on se rend bien
compte que les valeurs de l'Islam pour
certains ou certaines prime sur les
valeurs de la République parce qu'ils
ont cette méconnaissance véritablement
de l'islam et il manque quelque chose
par rapport à cela que le fait d'avoir
fait cette mise au point rude dès le
début de l'année ne pourrait pas être à
long terme contre-productif et produire
de la colère chez les musulmans de
France qui se sentiraient stigmatisés
par cette interdiction de la Baïa moi je
pense que
la manière la plus efficace pour lutter
contre le voile qui n'est pas comme vous
dites juste un vêtement religieux ou
autre mais un projet politique je pense
que la meilleure manière de lutter
contre cela c'est que les jeunes garçons
et filles connaissent l'histoire du
voile connaissent son sens savent
pourquoi elle est une pratique de
discrimination étudier les textes se
renseigner et une campagne nationale je
vais même plus loin pour expliquer aux
élèves ce que signifie le voile les
autorités religieuses les autorités
religieuses leur travail c'est de
travailler au sein de la religion je ne
parle pas de la religion là je parle de
l'histoire de la sociologie de la
psychologie et de la morale et de la
construction d'une société où on peut
vivre tous ensemble sans qu'ils ont une
campagne d'informations publiques je
pense qu'il y ait il faut qu'il y ait
l'origine du voile
à imaginer mais je pense qu'elle est
nécessaire pour que les jeunes garçons
et filles comprennent pour qu'ils
comprennent pourquoi cette cette
pratique on est contre cette pratique si
on l'interdit ce n'est pas une question
de racisme ou une question de rejet
d'une religion pour qu'il soit eux-mêmes
convaincu comme certains musulmans
d'ailleurs beaucoup de musulmans ont été
convaincus au début du 20e siècle
abandonnes
l'histoire du fer religieux existe à
l'école il enseigné sauf qu'avant donné
les jeunes n'acceptent pas en tout cas
l'interprétation que certains peuvent le
faire parce qu'ils ne sont pas
ils ne sont pas porteurs
publics
je pense que les les autorités
religieuses ont aussi un devoirs à faire
mais dans leur domaine dans le domaine
de la religion évidemment je sais que
l'État c'est par la religion de la
politique donc les relations au nom du
principe de laïcité a priori
complètement imposable je parle je parle
d'un travail historique un travail
sociologique je ne parle pas d'un
travail religieux je pense que si on
arrive pas à l'aborder comme cela je
pense qu'on aura toujours du mal à faire
face sur mes l'enseignement du fait
religieux vous savez c'est comme tout
enseignement des livres à l'école il est
tenu à une obligation d'objectivité dans
la transmission du savoir mais c'est le
sénateur qui vous disait qu'il y avait
déjà dans l'enseignement public des
enseignements en portant sur le fer
religieux et comme tous les
enseignements à l'école publique il y a
une obligation d'objectivité aucun
professeur jamais ce serait une faute de
sa part de pourrait se permettre de dire
que le voile c'est un instrument de
pression de la femme il n'a pas le droit
de le faire il y a tout simplement
objectivité mais il peut dire que
certains pensent
il peut dire que certains pensent et et
on a tout à fait le droit en tant que
professeur de dire quels sont les
opinions sur la question on peut dire
certains pensent que c'est un objet de
de discrimination un équilibre de la
femme
et donc
oserait-il le dire je pense que beaucoup
d'enseignants sont tout à fait
conscients de ce que veut dire du
politiquement une politiquement le voile
et la Baya et que certains je pense je
le souhaite
pour eux présentent les choses sous cet
angle là en disant voilà quel quel
problème pose le voile par exemple ou la
Baya dans la société française certains
pensent que voilà et on a tout à fait le
droit de l'exposé comme ça bien sûr en
équilibrant ils ont voilà certains vous
disent que c'est un outil d'émancipation
bon c'est tout à fait discutable
d'autres disent que c'est un outil de
discrimination on va expliquer pourquoi
voilà on a tout à fait la possibilité de
le faire en le faisant comme ça de façon
la plus objective possible en étant
neutre c'est-à-dire que on n'oublie pas
qu'on est fonctionnaires de la
République et qu'un fonction de la
République se doit d'être neutre et il a
la loi qui peut expliquer également
exactement alors justement ce qui est
intéressant dans les auditions reprises
dans le film c'est la non-unanimité des
responsables politiques de l'époque sur
la pertinence ou non d'une nouvelle loi
sur la laïcité on est frappé par
l'opinion de certains je pense à celle
de Nicolas Sarkozy par exemple une
nouvelle loi est une position dangereuse
avait-il déclaré à l'époque qu'est-ce
que c'est que ce faux débat avec d'un
côté les défenseurs de l'idéal qui
veulent une nouvelle loi et de l'autre
les abominables s'inclinant devant
l'extrémisme ce n'est pas la vérité
dit-il je suis opposé à toute forme de
signes religieux et en même temps très
réservé sur une nouvelle loi sur la
laïcité écoutez ces autres réactions
reprises dans le film que proposerai
volontiers à votre commission l'idée
d'une Charte de la laïcité définissant
cet équilibre entre droit et de voir
citoyen je suis personnellement
favorable à une législation interdisant
le port ostentatoire de tout signe
religieux je suis pour la circulaire
plutôt que pour la loi la loi s'impose
lorsque la laïcité est bafouée la
République défigurée c'est manifestement
le cas aujourd'hui
je suis réservé son principe d'une
nouvelle loi sur la laïcité mais ça ne
m'empêche pas d'être opposé au port d'un
signe religieux à l'école
et je trouve ça intéressant d'entendre à
quel point finalement personne n'était
vraiment d'accord et ça explique aussi
peut-être le flou et l'embarras de nous
tous et notamment des professeurs et des
chefs d'établissement si on reprend
l'exemple de l'école mais oui on le voit
bien moi j'étais surpris de voir que
j'étais député pas à ce moment-là mais
après en 2016 j'étais surpris de voir
que Nicolas Sarkozy soit pas
véritablement déterminé par rapport à
cela et que François Hollande qui paraît
peut-être plus plus souple plus souple
merci pour le beau pour l'adjectif
je crois qu'à un moment donné il y a eu
un consensus c'est à dire les peut-être
que la mission a montré au fur et à
mesure du temps aussi que vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure fort justement
comment donner les gens n'étaient pas
véritablement déterminé sur ce qui va le
faire une loi une circulaire un décret
une application etc etc et puis petit à
petit les choses se sont forgées
syndicat très engagés très engagés on va
dire à l'extrême gauche mais au-delà de
cela au-delà de cette minorité là je
crois que pour parler moi dans le pas
mal avec le monde enseignant même si je
n'ai pas une vision exhaustive beaucoup
d'enseignants sont soulagés de pouvoir
dire non ça ce n'est pas possible en
classe mais pas tous les politiques vous
savez où c'est moi je discute beaucoup
avec mes amis de tout bord politique ce
qui est c'est la fabrique du Sénat ça va
de fabrique du Sénat et des politiques
de gauche qui sont dans un certain
moment dans une bienveillance dans une
laïcité bienveillante ne sont pas
d'accord avec nous par rapport à cela et
certains de politique de gauche sont
d'accord aussi et on se rend compte que
les choses sont assez c'est assez
manichées à droite ils sont pour la loi
etc pour le l'interdiction à Baya et à
gauche on sent qu'il y a une réflexion
qui est en train de mûrir tous ensemble
des choses un déni et ils m'ont dit
l'autre jour on est un petit peu dans le
déni et cela d'ailleurs sont comprennent
fort bien qu'il faille maintenant
respecter cette loi cet engagement
peut-être plus quand même que la loi a
été votée à une écrasante majorité donc
j'entends bien ce que vous avez
rebroussé là les hésitations des uns et
des autres mais enfin
le résultat final est sans appel quoi
c'est cette loi a été et puis le débat
était sur la forme du texte finalement
on a besoin d'une loi est-ce que c'est
une loi qui est reconnue au collégien et
lycéen le droit à la liberté
d'expression en 1989 et seul le noir
peut venir limiter une liberté garantie
par la loi elle-même je voudrais quand
même pour conclure ce débat avec vous
vous rappeler cette phrase de
l'historien René Raymond qui faisait
partie de cette commission et qui ne
s'était pas reconnu dans cette loi votée
en 2004 à l'issue des travaux de la
commission et voilà ce qu'il déclarait
dans l'Obs à l'époque la réponse
politique actuelle a un caractère
absurde des dérisoires elle entretient
nos compatriotes dont l'illusion qu'il
suffirait de voter deux articles de loi
pour régler le problème de l'intégration
en réalité dit-il le voile est un leurre
qui dissimule l'enjeu central la
capacité de la France à intégrer des
populations nouvelles et l'acceptation
de la loi commune pour ses nouveaux
Français on se crispe sur un problème
ultra minoritaire alors que le vrai défi
est celui de l'intégration sociale et
professionnelle qu'en pensez-vous
razikani
je pense que qu'on ne peut pas les
dissocier le voile prend de l'ampleur au
sein de la société française mais il
reflète en prenant de l'ampleur qu'il y
a un problème d'intégration mais moi je
pense que le
l'objectif des islamistes de de voiler
toutes les femmes musulmanes a commencé
dans le monde musulman parce qu'ils ont
fait du voile leur arme de guerre dès le
début du 20e siècle ils ont réussi
d'ailleurs dans le monde musulman et
aujourd'hui il se poursuit en Occident
et il sera utilisé le voile pour contrer
l'intégration justement
ce que dit Madame Adnani c'est qu'il y a
un projet politique qui avance avec les
islamistes et qui veulent éviter
justement l'intégration et notamment en
passant par les femmes l'intégration des
des Français musulmans ou des musulmans
de France au modèle de vie occidentale
ils veulent les soutenir le voile fait
partie de cette stratégie et en même
temps la République française se doit de
travailler sur l'intégration et
notamment sur ces sur ces ghettos
véritables ghettos ces zones de
relégation sociale sur les tenues ne
suffisent pas c'est ce que dit on ne
peut pas on peut pas se contenter de
répression si vous voulez ou d'interdit
il faut aussi donner une vision positive
de ce qu'elle a République française
avec cette capacité à s'élever
socialement que la République doit
pouvoir offrir à chacun de ses enfants
et donc là il faut absolument réfléchir
à permettre à d'offrir à ses enfants
quels qu'ils soient un avenir meilleur
en France de manière à couper leur sous
le pied des islamistes
juste rappeler quand même qu'il y a pas
que les étrangers ou enfants d'étrangers
et qui sont tentés par l'intégrisme
religieux il y a d'autres des Français
de vieilles branches qui sont également
saisi par cette tentation et qui plus
globalement décroche par rapport au
principe de la République dire les
idéaux républicains peut-être que si on
en parle autant c'est parce que ça sonne
de plus en plus creux pour beaucoup de
gens
je crois qu'on se retrouve l'intégration
elle existe en tout cas elle existe elle
a des difficultés on se rend compte mais
il faut voir que c'est un combat
politique avant toute chose est-ce qu'on
va politique la République française en
tout cas la République doit lutter
contre cela pendant que certaines femmes
se battent en Iran justement pour ne
plus subir se voir ou l'accepter etc on
peut pas accepter nous en tout cas qu'en
France dans un pays de liberté que ça
puisse exister et ce sera le mot de la
fin merci merci à tous les quatre
d'avoir participé à cette émission merci
à vous de nous avoir suivis comme chaque
semaine émission et documentaire à
retrouver évidemment en replay sur notre
site internet public sénat.fr à très
vite sur public c'est non merci
[Musique]